Candid Truth.
>> What's up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it. If you don't
realize that we are living in the last
days, then you have not been paying
attention. Look at what just happened.
Developer and Chief Donald Trump
envisions new arch near Washington DC.
Why is this significant? This isn't just
some pretty monument that Trump wants to
put up because um America is 250 years
old. That's the story that they're
telling you. But this isn't just like,
"Oh, look at that. It's an archway." No,
this is significant. This is spiritual.
This is prophetic. Check this out. This
is what he wants to build. He's holding
the model in his hand. Here are the the
painting renditions of this thing. And
there are some interesting decorations
on this archway. We're going to look at
that stuff. Right here, you see the
golden angel on top. It's holding the
flame. and it's gold. Pay attention to
these things because who was the angel
that bared the torch light? The
lightbearer. Who was the angel that was
the light bearer? We're going to look
into that. Ezekiel 28:13 tells us a
description of Satan, who he used to be
before he fell. Thou hast been in Eden,
the garden of God. Every precious stone
was thy covering. The sardis, topaz, and
the diamond, the barrel, the onyx, and
the jasper, the sapphire, the emerald,
and the carbuncle. And gold, the
workmanship of thy tabits, and thy pipes
was prepared in thee in the day that
thou was created. So, Satan was decked
out. He had that bling bling, including
gold. And it continues, Ezekiel 28:14
says, "Thou art the anointed cherub that
coverereth." What do you think that
means? The cherub that coverereth. And I
have set thee so thou upon the holy
mount of God. Thou hast walked up and
down in the midst of the stones of fire.
So he was gold cherub that covers.
He was one of the cherubs that were
covering on the ark of the covenant. And
we talk about this in the video about
the Olympics that happened this year or
last year. And their closing ceremony
had this really odd scene where this guy
dropped down. He was completely decked
out in gold. And the announcer even said
he's descending to a desolate earth.
This is prophetic. This is when Satan is
bound to earth, a desolate earth for a
thousand years. If you don't know
anything about that, read Jeremiah 4,
starting with verse 23. It talks about a
desolate earth that is not going to be
made a full end. The earth was made
desolate by the Lord's fierce anger, but
he will not make a full end of it. And
this is where Satan will be bound for a
thousand years. But look, he was the
covering cherub before he fell. So, he
was the golden angel of light that was
holding that torch. What else do we have
here? We have an eagle. I know when you
think of eagle, you think of America,
but that's because we were born in this
culture. You got to go back to the
origins of this stuff. This stuff dates
back to Rome. The symbolism of the eagle
in Rome dates back to its founding myths
and its appro uh appropriation of the
symbols association with power,
strength, and divine authority.
Notice this doesn't just say with
militant strength. It says divine
authority. So, we know that this eagle
represents Rome and divinity. Check it
out. What else? What is this interesting
circle that's on the archway? That is
the laurel wreath. We talk about this
stuff a lot. Go back into our lives.
That's where most of our videos are.
They're in under our live section. And
watch our videos on Trump. Watch all the
videos we did on Donald Trump because we
go so deep. Minnow. A friend of ours
named Minnow. He brings so much
information and we cover so much of this
stuff. The Roman origin of the laurel
wreath is a direct adop adoption of a
Greek tradition which the Romans admired
and adapted to symbolize military
victory and status. In Greece, the
wreath was associated with Apollo. So,
this wreath that you see on here is not
just some fancy decoration like, "Oh,
that's pretty neat." Like a No, this
goes back to Apollo. This is Greek
mythology. Go back and watch our video
under live. Watch our video about
Washington DC exposed where we literally
went to Washington DC and we recorded
with our very own cameras all the Greek
and Roman gods that were everywhere.
There's literally a giant statue of
Zeus, a fountain out front. And when you
go inside, they have all the gods names
on the ceilings in gold. Apollo, Zeus,
all that. Washington DC is full of Greek
and Roman gods. And so this is saying
that it goes back to Apollo and awarded
to victors of athletic and poetic
contest. The Romans who often saw
military victory as the highest form of
achievement used the wreath to honor vic
victories uh victorious generals and
later their emperors.
Look at that. Okay. So, Roman Emperor
wreath, right? So, what is Trump saying?
What is Trump saying when he builds an
arch? It's literally called Arch Day
Trump. And and I've seen some articles
that say it's the Arch of Triumph, which
goes that's there's literally an Arch of
Triumph in Paris right now, and it looks
pretty similar. Why? Why do you have
this Roman Emperor wreath? Keep that in
mind.
So, this is nothing new. We have seen
this stuff, all this satanic pagan junk
going on in DC for a long time now. I
think this was from 2018. This is
literally a replica of the Temple of
Baal. This I know this is CBN News and
they're Christian and maybe they could
be biased, but look into this. Look up
the arch of Baal and you will see it
looks identical to this. It even has
this gap. This gap right here is in the
arch of Baal and they recreated it and
brought it to Washington DC. So get it
out of your mind that Washington DC is
just some Christian nation. This is a
pagan nation at its core.
Trump, this is on the Washington Post.
It says Trump eyes a triumphal arch to
mark I think this is interesting
language to mark America's 250th
anniversary. It goes on and says,
"Triumphal arches were widely used by
Romans." So, this isn't my bias,
conspiracy theory, Christian belief
system, right? This is the Washington
Post. They're just giving you the news
as it is. They're saying triumphal
arches were widely used by the Romans to
commemorate victories. Those Roman
arches inspired more recent structures
in Europe, most notably the Arch Day
triumph in Paris. All right. Now, it
goes on and it's going to tell you where
this arch is going to be placed.
Memorial Circle, that's where it's going
to be placed. Memorial Circle is an
underutilized
uh is underutilized considering that it
serves as a gateway to Washington. Now,
gateway, I think that's very interesting
language as well. You look into it. I
didn't actually put it in this. Look up
the occult purposes or the occult
meanings behind arches. They are
spiritual portals, gateways. Serves as a
gateway to Washington, said Duncan
Stroke, an architectural professor at
the University of Notre Dame. It's a big
traffic circle. It's fine, but it could
have something in the middle of it that
would be very noteworthy and it should
be beautiful. So, where are they going
to put this archway in a big traffic
circle? Right, that's what it says. This
is Paris. This is the ark of the triumph
in Paris. Now look at this symbol. Do
you see a sun? A blatant symbol of a
sun. All roads lead to Rome, right?
Literally, all these roads are leading
to the Roman triumphant ark. So, and
it's in the symbol of a sun. That's not
a coincidence. Here it is again with a
traffic circle. So, this article we just
read by Washington Post, it's not just
some like, oh, we have an original idea.
Let's put it in a traffic circle. No,
they're doing this on purpose. This is
done over and over.
Notice which direction the traffic is
moving. I don't know which side of the
road they drive on in France, but it
obviously appears that no matter which
direction you drive in a country, you go
counterclockwise. Keep that in mind.
Yes, sources indicate the pro proposed
Arch Trump monument would be built in a
traffic circle, specifically the
memorial circle in Virginia. This
roundabout is located at the foot of the
Arlington Memorial Bridge across from
the Lincoln Memorial, and it's going to
be in this traffic circle. Now, what is
so significant about that traffic
circle? Why is it significant that there
will be people nonstop in this tourist
place driving circles around the arch of
trump that goes back to Rome because of
something called circumambulation is the
act of moving around a sacred object or
idol. Circumambulation
of temples or deity images is an
integral part of Hindu Buddhist
devotional practices known in Sanskrit.
It is also present in other religions
including Christianity. I don't ever
remember anything like that in
Christianity, Judaism and Islam.
Are you getting mental images in your
mind right now? Especially with the word
Islam. So people will be driving circles
around this monument that is a Roman
portal for the spirit world. Oh my with
Oh, okay. We're going to keep going. So
I was looking into it to see, well, what
direction do traffic circles go? And I
found it on this website called Federal
Highway Administration. And I think this
logo up here is pretty interesting. This
is called a trilis. I can't remember
what it's called, but it's a it's like
this three-piece yin-yang thing that
looks like a 666. It also has to do with
death and renewal and rebirth and the
same stuff that we've been seeing over
and over with this Charlie Kirk stuff,
the phoenix rising out of the ashes, the
oraoris, all that stuff. But this is
just the company that builds traffic
circles. But I think everything
everything about our architecture,
everything about the way our land is
laid out, it's not just draw, it's not
just pulled out of a hat, guys. Like
there is meaning behind all this stuff.
People need to wake up and see what's
going on. Please give this video a
thumbs up. Thank you guys. Okay, so I
already highlighted what's important
here. It's a counterclockwise flow.
That's which direction the traffic goes.
Counterclockwise circumambulation.
In some other traditions, the
counterclockwise direction is ritually
significant. So Islam and Judaism, they
do this thing where they have a a
counterclockwise circumambulation around
the synagogue around Mecca. This is
spiritual. This is ritualistic right
here. You see it happening. The traffic
circle going the same direction as these
people walking around Mecca. So now
picture in the middle of that traffic
circle a big ark of Baal. I mean sorry
arc of Constantine. Oh I mean sorry arc
of Trump. Get it guys? Like this is not
just some coincidence. This is not just
like oh Trump really likes this type of
architecture. This is all strategically
planned. This is all satanic at its
core. And it's super prophetic. the
significance of the arch of Constantine,
which Constantine's very significant in
prophecy because he was one of the first
ones that really made a church and state
that was supposedly Christian but was
really a mingling of paganism and
Christianity together, a co-exist
movement. He wanted to unite Christians
and pagans together and he made it law.
Why is that significant? Because in the
last days, there's going to be a one
world religion that's enforced by law,
by death decree. And we're going to get
into that. The significance of the arch
of Constantine was to serve as a
powerful political propaganda
commemorating Emperor Constantine's
victory over
uh Maxentius
at the battle of Milvian Bridge and
linking him to the glory of the past
emperors like Traan, Hadrienne, and
Marcus. Okay. Anyway, the point is look
at this right down here where I have it
underlined.
It says that these monuments are to
present
to present Constantine as a legit. Okay.
So the monument is to present
Constantine in a certain way. So this
monument will be to present Trump in a
certain way. And what's it say? As a
legitimate heir to their success and to
promote his authority and legitimacy,
especially after civil war. Think about
what we talked about in those Charlie
Kirk videos. There's three Charlie Kirk
videos. Go back and watch those things.
If you have not seen the light of what's
going on, there's a lot going on behind
the scenes with that stuff. It is a
political push towards a one world
religion. It's all about Oh, you guys
got to got to check it out. But they are
talking about civil war. They're saying
you don't realize the dragon you've
awakened, the fire that you've just
caused. And and it's all about inciting
a civil war because these elitists, they
bring order out of chaos. So they create
and manufacture the chaos so they can
come in and bring the peace. Right? And
I just think it's interesting that
Constantine, this ark of Constantine was
erected after a civil war.
Its construction also reflected the
changing political and religious
landscape. Wait a minute. Wait a minute.
It also reflected the changing
political. Is our politics changing?
Well, if you go back to some of our
Trump videos, you'll see that Trump's
saying he's the last president, that
you're not going to have to vote anymore
because he's king and there are banners
of him looking like a Roman Caesar and
all this stuff. And are we seeing a
change in our religious landscape? I
think we are. By incorporating new
reliefs that along with existing ones
were used to shape the narrative of a
triumphant ruler, a bringer of peace and
a patron of Rome. Has Trump been uh is
he being uplifted as some bringer of
peace? Oh yes. In his speeches, he's
talking about we're going to bring peace
and safety. And that's exactly what the
Bible says that the antichrist is going
to say. I'm not saying Trump is the
antichrist. He's because I don't even
believe there's a oneman antichrist. I
do believe that Satan is going to appear
as Christ. But I believe that Trump is
being set up as a decoy antichrist so
that a supernatural being can appear on
the scenes as an angel of light, destroy
the antichrist, and then all believers
will believe that he that Satan is the
true Christ because he he defeated the
antichrist. Anyway, a bringer of peace.
Peace and safety. That's what the Bible
says. When they say peace and safety,
sudden destruction will come upon them.
Why is that happening? Because there's
going to be a one world religion that's
based on coexist. We can all worship
together. We all worship the same God.
We just have different languages to God
and different paths to God. But we can
all agree that we believe in God. Right?
That's the coexist religion that will
soon be to come. And it will look so
close to Christianity that millions will
fall for it. Just like all the other
cults out there like the Catholicism and
the Mormonism and all these other cults
that look like Christianity, but they
are not. Has Trump ever been compared to
Constantine?
>> Through your leadership, you embody the
values of our Christian faith and love
for the gospel. You remind me of the
great Roman Emperor Constantine the
Great.
You remind me of the great Roman Emperor
Constantine. And what did Trump say? He
said that he is going to promise a
golden age. These articles have been
coming out since January. We've been
talking about this on our channel for
months now. For an entire year, we've
been talking about all these
connections. Listen,
>> the golden age of America begins right
now. From this day forward, our country
will flourish and be respected again all
over the world. We will be the envy of
every nation, and we will not allow
ourselves to be taken advantage of any
longer during every single day of the
Trump administration.
I will very simply put America first.
>> So, he's talking about bringing America
back to the golden age. Why is that
important? because this goes all the way
back to Rome and all the way back to
these pagan countries. The the golden
age is the age of Aquarius. Um, esoteric
writers like Alice Bailey and Helena
Bavotssky, they were talking about the
year 2025 would be when the
externalization of the hierarchy would
be when the spirit world would enter
into our physical world and we would
enter into a new paradigm shift of a of
a plane of existence where spirituality
and where spirits and the physical dwell
together in the golden age. So here we
are in the golden age. Emperor imperial
propaganda, the concept of a new golden
era was also a long-standing theme in
imperial Roman propaganda. So this goes
back to Rome, right? Constantine's
imagery and messages drew on these
traditions while adapting them for a
Christian context. So Constantine tried
to twist this pagan belief into a
Christian context connection to the
what? the sun god because it all goes
back to the sun which is Satan the su n
Satan's
number one uh disguise is the sun god
whether it's raw the allseeing eye or
whether it's Baal or any of these things
are all just different representations
for different cultures and different
time periods of the sun god because
Satan is going to bring the world into
sun worship going the mandatory
rest on Sunday for climate change, for
family, for religion. All these things
are coming. This is something that's on
the books. Blue laws in every state in
America, blue laws are on the books. All
it is going to take is for somebody to
say, "Let's make it happen."
some kind of catastrophe, calamity,
chaos for them to say, "Look, this
country has gotten out of control. We
need to get this country back to God.
We're going to force everyone to go to a
church that teaches morality."
Look at this. Economic stability.
Constantine's introduction of a new
stable gold. H. Have we been talking
about a new form of currency? Maybe
digital IDs or something like that.
something that can be controlled because
if you don't worship according to the
beast's way then you will have your
ability to buy and sell cut off. Donald
Trump Newsweek says Donald Trump vows to
make America more religious than ever
before. Look guys, this is a country
that was founded on freedom of religion.
You can worship any way you want. So,
how is Donald Trump going to vow to make
that word is a forceful word to make
America more religious than ever before?
This is very interesting stuff. Check
this out.
>> And you know, they work right out of the
White House. They've never done that.
That's never been done before. No other
president allowed that. I think you know
they say separation.
They say separation between church and
state. They told me. I said, "All right,
let's forget about that for one time."
We said really the separation I don't
know
>> separation of church and state he's like
you know what I don't know if that's bad
or not why do we got separation of
church and state let's forget about that
for a moment Donald Trump said that
let's forget about church and state for
a moment why
>> is that a good thing or a bad thing
>> because of this
>> Charlie who spent his life speaking with
the critics of these traditions
ultimately became convinced that we
needed not just a political realignment
but also a spiritual reawakening. We
did. And we have to bring back religion
to America because without borders, law
and order, and religion, you really
don't have a country anymore. We want
religion brought back
to America. We want to bring God back
into our beautiful USA like never
before. We want God back.
>> Notice they're saying we want God back.
God is a generic word. It mean it can
mean anything. It can mean any god,
whoever your god is. Now, the fact that
he is just saying what he's saying is
just super creepy because I have an
understanding of prophecy and how the
end times is going to push for a one
world religion. And he and this whole
crowd is just brainwashed, emotionally
driven at this supposed memorial for
Charlie Kirk that was nothing more than
a political rally that had 90,000 people
there 11 days after the death of Charlie
Kirk. You tell me how that happens. How
can you make an event like that happen
with flares like pyrochnics,
LED screens, graphics, merch,
speakers, bands, everything? It's It
doesn't happen. Okay, guys. It takes
months to make an event like that
happen. And they did it. It was It
happened 11 days after the death of
Charlie Kirk. And what were they doing?
They were saying his wife was saying,
"Go to church next Sunday." And the
Sunday after this, you've awakened the
dragon. And and I'm going to bring
religion back to America. Now, this guy,
I can't remember his name. Senator
Barry, I think he is on Trump's board
and listen to what he's saying. This is
so crazy.
>> Something that something I really
encourage I don't see a big it's harder
to see a big federal role for this. I
think this is more a question of state
and local law is um reinvigorating where
possible Sabbath rest laws. To be very
specific like it used to this was
basically the norm through as best I
looked into this some. I'm working on
some research on this um really going
literally dating back to Constantine um
and his recognition of Christianity in
the Roman Empire that you've had a
pretty consistent tradition in in
Western civilization of of taking like
taking Sunday off uh from from commerce.
Um, this of course this is a tradition
that has roots not only in Christianity
but in in Judaism, right? Um, and and
keeping the Sabbath holy. Um,
>> and having a having a time not only for
it's not merely from rest in the sense
of of of abstinence from work, but it's
it's rest for it's rest for time with
God, time worshiping God. It's rest for
time with community or and even before
in between is time with family. um the
the lack one of the things that I think
has been so um so harmful to the world
of work and how we think about work is
the lack of of kind of well-defined and
shared times for rest. Um one of the
best uh pieces on this from a a secular
secular-ish author um named uh Judith
Schulvitz put this in the Atlantic a few
years ago called Why You Never See Your
Friends Anymore. Um, and she opens with
talking about the Soviet experiment in
abolishing the 7-day uh week, replacing
it with a 5-day week where just 1if of
all the people are randomly assigned
like you will have this day off, you
will have this day off. It was a
debacle. Um, and within a few years even
the Soviets had to admit this was a very
bad idea. like the these are like you
know these are the masters of the even
the goolog people thought like thought
that this was a bad idea like we can't
keep doing this. Um so having that
having more of that steadier rhythm of
work and rest would be so much healthier
so much happier and help people more
readily connect with the purpose of
their work. Being able to push back from
your work allows you to more readily see
it as service to God, service to family,
service to community. um than the the
weird um kind of soup of half rest, half
work that we all seem to be floating in
all the time.
>> So, you hear what he's saying, right? He
said Sabbath rest. Sabbath in the Bible
is the seventh day of the week, which is
Saturday. But he's not talking about
that. He's saying we need a a day of all
this stuff with family and God and all
this stuff, but what day will they pick?
What day will it be? Because what day is
the government shut down on? What day
does your mail not run? What day is it
that you can't go to the DMV? What day
is it on certain states you can't buy
alcohol? You can't buy a car. They are
called Sunday laws. Blue laws. Look it
up. Blue laws. They're already on the
books for every state in America. And
they're they're choosing this time of
great calamity that they have
manufactured. They have manufactured the
chaos so that they can bring in the
peace. And they're making it sound so
good. That's why it's deception because
it sounds so close to the truth that you
will go for it. And you're gonna say,
"This sounds great. This country needs
to get back to God." Actually saw a post
on Facebook that was like the good old
days or something and it showed,
remember when everything was closed on
Sunday and 100% of the comments were
saying, "This was so great. It was such
a great time. I wish we'd get back to
this." So, this is going to be accepted
by all people, including atheists,
because who doesn't like a day off?
These are people who believe in climate
change and all that stuff, and they
think, "Oh, it's great for the
environment. It's a green Sabbath." All
this stuff. There's greens.org. Check
that out. In 321 AD, Emperor Constantine
issued a law that made Sunday a day of
rest in the Roman Empire, but it wasn't
a universal religious enforcement. The
law stated that judges, city dwellers,
and all tradesmen should rest on the
what? The venerable day of the sun. Now,
when you look back at this law, they
said that all shops must be closed on
the venerable day of the sun. If you are
caught judizing is what it said. If you
were caught Judaizing, you would be
punished. Judaizing included keeping the
seventh day Sabbath, which is the fourth
commandment of God. And what does
Revelation say? that those who keep the
commandments of God will have right to
the tree of life and enter into the
city. So, Satan, the lawless one, wants
to come in disguise as an angel of light
to make laws of worship that look so
close to the truth that if you don't
understand Bible prophecy, that if
you're not reading your Bible, then you
will compromise and go along with it
because it it looks good, it looks like
peace and safety and coexist and all
that stuff. That is compromising on what
God commanded because Constantine said,
"Keep the day of the sun and if you keep
God's holy day, you will be persecuted."
If you guys have not checked out
Washington DC Exposed, go to our live
section. Watch it because it will show
you beyond a shadow of a doubt. This is
not a Christian nation, never has been.
Everything of everything that goes on in
Washington is all pagan. Check it out.
If you haven't seen who is the Rainman,
check that video out. These videos go
back a ways. So, click on our live tab,
go back and watch this one because it
talks about the ark of Baal. It talk the
rainman is Baal. Bale worship is
prevalent in our culture today. Check
out our channel. We got a lot of videos.
Most of them are under the live section
as you see right here. This stuff is so
deep. There's way too much to cover in
this one live right here. If you guys
would like to support this ministry,
please go to canatruth.org. We are
completely 100% donor-based except for
what we make when we travel to speak at
churches. We will come to your church.
Please invite us. We've been to churches
completely free. We've paid out of
pocket to do it. But if your church
wants to hear us come and give some
presentations, you can go to
canatruth.org and click on our booking
tab. If your church can't afford it or
whatever, just email us directly. we can
work something out. You can support us
through Cash App, Vinmozelle, PayPal. We
even have Patreon. If you guys like
t-shirts and hoodies and mugs and
pillows and all that, we have all that
on our store on cantruth.org.
I love you guys. We cannot do this
without you. We need your support.
Please like this video, click subscribe,
share it with all your family and
friends so they will not be deceived in
these last days. We'll see you next time
on Can of Truth.